hey what is up guys in cabbie HD here
and this is what is on my android phone
right now or what is on my Nexus 6 this
is inspired by a post recently from
Google Plus and Twitter and Facebook
basically where I posted this just
talking about lollipop in general so
yeah I'm just going to talk about what's
in my phone it's been a while since I
did one of these so it's the
back-to-school season last one for me
last semester so a lot of the apps we'll
see here are School inspired and they're
here for school reasons but that's
basically as much explanation as I have
now this is yes the 64 gig white Nexus 6
and I guess if you want to talk about
what's on my phone this is a skin deep
brand skin I'll have a link in the
description below if you want to check
out this exact one I don't always carry
this as my daily phone in fact if you
saw me at CES my daily phone was the
oneplus one for the battery life but now
that I'm here at school I can I can mind
the shorter battery life for the Nexus 6
and just pop it on the turbo charger in
between classes this is my setup and
you'll notice this setup I have is
usually pretty simple and this is
because I switch phones pretty often
during the course of the year and so
when I do I want it to be easy to move
in between phones and set up the next
phone so I usually don't have a whole
ton of widgets and stuff on my
homescreen that's just about setting up
the apps so I'm using the Google
Experience launcher as I usually do with
most of my phones and these are the apps
I have on my main home screen so on the
bottom of the dock I guess those are
your most telling most important apps
the phone hangouts is what I use for SMS
the camera the Google camera I like
taking photo spheres with that so that's
why I have that there and Phoenix that's
my Twitter app a lot of people ask me
all the time is it worth the price I
think it's a couple dollars in the Play
Store for this app and a lot of people
are hesitant to spend that much but I
use it every day so it seems like it is
worth it I'm getting my money's worth
out of this app it's got a material
design update coming soon it's already
pretty good looking so that's an app I
use all the time Google Tasks I'll have
a link to as many as I can below in the
description if they aren't like named
recognizable keep Spotify my little
Google folder here has maps Google+
YouTube and inbox I switch back and
forth between inbox and Gmail a lot but
there you go
and then Play Store and then I have this
widget up here this I actually hadn't
used for
while but it's the mkbhd clock widget
you actually need to have super widget
installed so once you install super
widget pro and then you can find the
link below to the mkbhd clock it's
pretty needs a little bowtie logo and
that's what that is so people were
asking about that I can actually tap on
it and get to my clock so that's cool
too so that's the widget I have and then
the Google stuff to the left to the
right is the second most-used group of
apps I have so the YouTube studio app
SoundHound
for identifying songs after ship is a
new one I was using packaged buddy
before but I found that this is much
cleaner and much better looking for
tracking packages so I switched to using
this one and I've liked it a lot vsco
cam for editing photos uber instagrams
getting pretty good snapchat oh god
snapchat I've actually started using
snapchat more nowadays and I don't
really know what I'm doing with snapchat
but if you want to follow my story it's
mkbhd and you can find the stuff there
next up is SoundHound and I use that for
listening to music pretty often
I guess second in frequency to Spotify
but sound town is pretty neat and it's
actually a really good looking app so if
you happen to find some cool sounds you
like like I have on SoundHound and you
start to play them of course I want to
turn the volume down you can see you can
drag along it's pretty cool user
interface you get to spot in the song
you want this up-and-down vertical stuff
it's very well organized interesting
looking a notification here but I think
that'll look better in the future so I
like sound have SoundCloud and then
there's the Philips hue app which I use
to control some of the Philips hue
lights I have in this room so if I want
to turn all the lights off I can do that
if I want to turn them all back on I can
do that too there you saw them all just
turn off and then I'll go back to the
blue that I had on before so they all
turn back on I don't know if you can see
that in the background pretty cool and
then reddit news for reddit and then
right over to the right is my Google
Calendar basically this is the app or
widget that I use it's called the today
calendar widget that just lets me see an
agenda view of all the stuff in my
calendar as you can see it's just
basically a bunch of classes now and
practice so that's what I'm using and it
can tap up here to get to Google
Calendar but that's what it looks like
and that is the simple way of showing my
homescreen
like the YouTube studio app I use that a
lot more now again in the most used apps
I like after ship that's been something
I've discovered recently that I like a
lot now not a lot of games on my phone
you've probably noticed just a whole
bunch of utility and fun school like
stuff so that's why I have a bunch of
these apps here but hey if you have any
questions I'll be hanging out in the
comments section below just talking
about the apps and whatever Android 5.0
stuff you want to talk about on lollipop
so there you go thank you for watching
if you enjoyed it feel free to leave a
thumbs up below
and I'll talk to you guys in the next
one peace